joining us here from Fox Sports and
whose awesome gym unbreakable
performance is getting me ready for my
run which will air on NFL Network with
the run rich run campaign and behalf of
st. Jude Children's Research Hospital
two weeks from today Jay Glazer
how are you glaze my dude how are you
brother how's that intro did I cover it
on love that was fantastic all that you
know what I appreciate it
I appreciated a be sent out all those
tweets Flacco getting traded Kyler
Murray committing to the NFL just so you
could intro me like that yeah I mean and
that I didn't even cover you know I
guess a third of it or two thirds of it
if you want to be I guess
generous let's get to the football
aspect there is no off season you know
the cameras don't stop suddenly rolling
on all the drama that goes on that's why
it's that's why you and I you know
people like us we love it we can't get
it up and we even though the offseason
for us it's man it's just in the NFL is
you know people still ask me you know
you're doing so much stuff and I still
go to combine and and Pro Bowl sometimes
Senior Bowl and training camp and it's
like hey how come you're still going
around there so like this this is like
your this storyline this drama is
becomes part of your blood it's become
so your family that your that your your
friends and family over the last you
know quarter of a century of our lives
yeah there is nothing better well I know
you got the athletic and you got
Bellator and you got again merging vets
and players and you got unbreakable
performance but I guess the bread and
butter and all this stuff is what you're
talking about worthy with you as the NFL
information what what can you tell us
about the relationship between the
Giants and and Odell Beckham jr. as we
currently sit here a couple weeks before
the new league year Jay what you look
I'm a little surprised that there was
such a backlash when I put it out it was
almost like you know John Merrow said
never said what he said last year it was
almost like they never had friction last
year it's almost what I mean there
certainly was and you know I was asked
for a Bowl prediction on the athletic I
said I think Odell well I said I think
I'll back home will get traded this
offseason and you know wasn't I wasn't
reporting it would happen but I looked
at my little crystal ball which is my
own fault head
look there's a couple reasons I know
people looking to go there's so much
dead money look I think when they
brought him Pat tremor last year
you got sacrum Berkeley and I would kill
to you this also we sought the Giants
for man there's just a couple pieces
away they brought in solder and that's
not the case there's a reason why they
have the second pick of the draft and
now you look at it they have more holes
going into this year than they did last
or maybe now we know what those holes
really are and you look around you
looking you say you know what kind of
bargaining chip are they gonna have here
really the only thing is oh tell they
need help they need a quarterback they
need offensive lineman they need pass
rushers they need linebackers they need
secondary the only thing they have
really is Odell and last year they
thought about doing it last year there's
teams that were talking to him about
trading them at the trade deadline teams
call them and you know I think this year
if they're smart about it they do look
at it and they say man we can get this
is what we can get some some value for
to help build up our picks but also
again they hate that happened don't
forget about his interview with little
Wayne last year like this has not been
the perfect marriage I would all the
Giants have not been a sunny you know
drama-free say they need some marriage
counseling the last couple years well I
guess then you know Antonio Brown and
the Steelers that their marriage
counseling is broken down and they
appear to be headed for divorce I'm
gonna put the tweet that oh that Antonio
Brown sent out he he sent out a whole
bunch of tweets yesterday saying hey you
know I got 10 question you give me 10
questions I'll give you the straight
truth and there was a tweet that was
sent out in regards to what's going on
with you and Big Ben and he said Ben has
an owners mentality to call out players
in addition to all of that went ahead
and said that there was a lack of
respect from so where where does this
all go from here with him tweeting out a
video Jay saying I'm out with three
years left on his contract how do you
see this playing out
so here's what a B needs to understand
these teams they really judge you
circus versus skill right so we all know
about a B skill it's ridiculous it's
someone on that but in order for a B to
get the value that he wants he has to
look at circus versus skill and he is
just building his circus up he needs to
stop doing all this he needs to bring
the circus down he needs to look at it
and say I I want them to I want every
team out there to look at me just upon
my skill to drive up my bargaining power
but because there's a circus that now
surrounded you know if there's one team
that says you know what we don't want to
deal with that circus we're pulling out
of it that's one team too many if I'm
the player I have to look and go it's
one team too many I don't want that I
want to make sure I got 31 other teams
they're all vying for my love here so
that love could turn into some more
green
so does this which which happens first
then I guess Odell and Antonio Brown
we're talking about
I mean crystal will happen it I predict
I think you know and you know go back to
that a little bit free funny because
yeah my tweets which where it says you
know the only time I'm not dropping
f-bombs is pretty much when the red
lights on right it's just how I talk to
Jersey thing but I got the same kind of
hate that I did a few years ago when I
came out on Fox NFL Sunday and I said
Jim Harbaugh will not be back as head
coach the 49ers even if they win the
Superbowl and I got so much hate like
I'm trying to get the dude fired I'm not
the owner of the team I'm not trying to
get anybody fired and I'm not the owner
who giant I'm not trying to get O'Dell
traded O'Dell last year we're trying to
get a hotel traded O'Dell last year what
who did that you know the interview with
Lil Wayne and and now that issue did not
me and you know it was Jim Harbaugh who
had the falling-out with people inside
that building all I'm doing is putting
it out information that I kind of gather
and glean and you guys are shooting the
messenger but when you guys shoot the
messenger in a way that y'all did I'm
gonna you know I'm not just gonna sit
there I think just because you're in the
public eye doesn't mean you have to sit
there and let people just trash
you your mom your kid your kids mom your
mom's kid all that it should it doesn't
have to happen that way why people kind
of get a little carried away you know
with you know the hate and anger dude
we're just in sports no I know that I
put that off when your kid comes home
with a D on his report card no I put
that tweet up right now but it would
read like one of those mullah reports
totally rejected right now it would just
be we it just be just dark lines across
the screen cuz we couldn't show what you
were saying but the reason why I asked
again is just you know obviously the new
league year is coming up and that's
usually when these things come up and
pop and it sure looks like you know
obviously Odell and the Giants could try
and continue counseling and and and keep
going
but it looks like this Browns and you
know obviously Antonio Brown the
Steelers is over certainly since he was
liking so again the circus part if they
don't get if enough team say we don't
want the circus and if a bee wants a new
contract which is what it seems like and
a team says because that's the whole
thing if he trade Odell you'll have to
give him a new contract teams getting
them with the contract BAM with a B if
you wants to do contract then a team now
has to value okay do we want to give up
pics plus do a whole new contract form
and there's a lot there they got to work
together on that that's a lot and you
know I don't know the answer to that
question because the Steelers certainly
aren't going to say okay let's just get
rid of them for a for then I'm going to
do that especially look Amari Cooper he
was the one panned out well
both those players a feud is better than
Amari Cooper right mm-hm so you know
you're gonna go suddenly look to a team
and say okay we won a one plus and
you're gonna have to give a new contract
for somebody who's just trashing our
team I think other teams are they look
it and go now you just try to unload him
you know it's like he's taking away his
leverage because every other team's
gonna look at him say you guys just
don't want to back anyway just give him
to us for a three and and we'll take him
off her hands I think that's the
strategy other teams are going to use I
don't want to in particular has been you
know scare it off a little bit by his a
team that was interested and scared off
by you know all the doors right now do
you want to tell me which conference
that teams in Jack
all right mmm it's my match you're my
job to ask that so looking looking over
the steering wheel J but before we move
on to the run here for a second
which Pennsylvania's star do you think
is most likely to get tagged foals or
levy on bail how do you see either of
those things I don't understand the
Le'Veon Bell part of it and here's why
if they want to try and transition tag
them let's say okay and let's say like
nobody's gonna nobody's gonna suddenly
trade with them because that lets say
you tagged them
you then need the cooperation the
Steelers will of the player in the agent
try and get a deal worked out with a new
team and then trade them I don't see
them cooperating at all number one
number two okay if so that if they
transition them the smartest thing would
be for another team to come up with a
deal that is just like the point you
know kind of like what the Vikings did
with the Seahawks and not you can't use
poison pill but something along the
lines you know for that Steve Hutchinson
deals right something where they know
the Steelers can't match if a team does
that still is no match Steelers don't
get any compensation if the Steelers
just let them go for your free agency
they get probably a third-round pick
back as compensation so I don't really
understand at all
the thought process of transition
tagging them and then trying to trade
them because another team was going to
want them it's just really going to work
out a deal
that they know the Steelers will not
financially match doesn't really make
any sense to me at all that that would
be their their strategy unless it's just
unless egos getting in the way but I
just I don't see that I don't I don't
get that in foals you think they
franchise tag them and figure out how to
trade them where do you think that is
they're gonna figure something out there
I would think so because there's well I
think they got a judge what the market
will be but I think it'd be smart for
them okay alright glaze the Rich Eisen
run Rich run campaign for st. Jude is
officially totally big-time underway you
can go to
nfl.com / run rich run to donate to
saint jewel truth Jane st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital every
dollar matters and I got to tell you you
know when you came on a few months ago
and offered for me to come work out it
unbreakable performance here in Los
Angeles I jumped at the chance and I I
feel pretty good I mean you want to do
you want to lay it out there what you
think well chances are two weeks gone
through the Felix yes or no everybody in
your studio be honest do you want to
chime in on that guys yes yes all right
I'm staring up I'm staring at them right
now Jay so they have to say that that
response no you know don't think one but
by the way st. Jude you know we went
down there for Fox NFL Sunday a few
years ago and oh my god that you know
the way they make it comfortable for
those families those children and the
the joy that give these kids while
they're going through the hardest thing
in the world when you can't me and said
this I'm like it's st. Jude I'm all-in
they are they are so incredible and what
they do they are oh god bless and
they're walking blessing hi grace um so
I love I've always loved what you've
done Matt at the place is amazing
but you have worked your butt off to it
and the fact that look you know we've
had a lot of fun we try and do it
unbreakable as we try to make it you
know this community of this family and
you know so you want to come in there
every day and work out you want to you
know make sure you come in and bust your
buck cause you can't wait to see your
your family and your friends and you
have you know the fact of the Superbowl
you you already broke sub 6 which was
almost correct our goal for you right
yeah and now we can't have Liu Shan Bo
did that no shows the work that you have
put in we're very proud of you thanks
master your plot you've had this whole
community behind you and I I mean I
started telling our coaches the other
day hey man I want to push this guy to a
sub five you know sub five seven I know
exactly I'm wondering I'm wondering if
that's possible but I'm never gonna put
anything it was great the other day guys
I'm working out at Glaser's gym going
through the workout which is just I mean
they it it really is all about being
unbreakable and somebody was went
through the workout couldn't make it
didn't make it didn't make it through
the workout we were seeing that
individuals breakfast actually oh and it
was lunchtime and it was funny I felt
like the end of officer and gentleman
like I was mailed Brydon off on the
motorcycle like because I've made it
right through everything and I kind of
looked at the new charges that were
coming in it was this person's first
time and I'm broke I've never seen that
moving are you serious oh my gosh I
guess I am dating myself but anyway the
workouts they're a great Jay and I look
forward to doing it you're sent are you
you're sending tell me you're told
because this is what I told rich I tell
everybody I tell especially our fighters
and I use it for our football players
they don't ever show that your tire ever
I don't see hands on our hips I don't
want you can see fatigue on somebody's
the moment our fighters see somebody the
slightest bit tired and we forget that
we're tired we sharpen our weapons and
that's the point we push our breaking
point and push our breaking point and
push our breaking point so then you
could look back though Oh ma'am I'm
tired all that stuff that I do with
these guys that's exhausting and you're
able to kind of come back to life and
it's just you could play these little
mental games with yourself and you're
part of it you know like you know when
your kid and you're laying down your
exhaust you just did some you're so
tired and also and your friend your
brother comes up and whines you you jump
up a run after them all son you forget
that you're tired right so you can
control it with the four inches between
your ears and and and what's behind your
ribcage and that's what we coached there
and T's here more than anything what's
behind the ribcage in between the ears
right and rich got it and I think you
you know the other day I told you even
when you're running you know don't
cruise through that finish line go after
that finish line swing away throw to go
man just you know we want knockouts in
our place and I think that's when you
turn around and started coaching that
other guy was throwing up it that's
right I was it was great Jay I love you
I know you're jumping off of a vacation
to call in so we'll chat next week love
you guys Friday buddy right back at you
that Shay Glaser the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience
you